Mary is with us in Florida welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show Mary I'm Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up well I just recently sold
my home and paid off almost all of my
debt and but I'm 59 and I do not have
any money in retirement so I was
wondering what your advice would be
instead of taking all the money that I
have and putting it into a home I was
thinking that maybe I should beef up an
investment account but I know that your
steps say that's like borrowing money to
invest right okay so how much how much
debt do you currently have that you have
not paid off well I have a lease that
has 30 months remaining and it's 400 a
month but I just didn't think it would
be wise to turn that over yet okay and
do you have anything else you debt no I
am cash flowing my daughter's college
right now
and no other debt okay and how much
money do you have that is in your
account today with the sale of your
house after you paid off some of the
debts well I have a total of 290 I put
ten thousand in my emergency fund and I
have about five thousand in an account
because I haven't done my eighteen taxes
yet and let's get ready to do them
that's right but if I was going to do a
step I'm self-employed and if I was
going to do a step I wanted to I've been
waiting to figure out what to do before
and what do you earn what's your
household income you
it's about $70,000 in here what kind of
a business have you got I do
small business bookkeeping individual
very good yeah okay so it's fairly low
impact so you can do more of it and do
it longer that's a good news yeah okay
all right so what price range was the
home you sold it was it sold for five
hundred and eighteen thousand got it
okay and what city do you live in in
Florida I am just north of Palm Beach
Florida okay all right huh as in the
Jupiter market like that just just about
you okay I don't know where you are okay
well I would like to stay in the
$300,000 range for home and so I was
thinking maybe invest 200 into the house
and take a small mortgage for ten years
and here's where here's what we've got
to get here's our ratios here's the
three or four numbers that are the big
numbers in your equation okay the by age
70 something okay 15 years 75 okay 15
years from now we have to have a nest
egg in a paid-for house mm-hmm
we currently have 290 thousand to do
that with and we have $70,000 a year to
do that with mm-hmm okay and so that's
you're working to 75 okay mm-hmm if we
you know or 272 or whatever if we say 12
years I don't care but you've got
$70,000 a year and two hundred ninety
thousand to accomplish that because if
you do not have a paid-for house when
you're through working you're going to
have a major problem because it
destabilizes your whole situation have a
mortgage when you are retired do not
want to go into retirement retirement
with note with a mortgage so we've got
to clear the house the second thing then
every dollar we pay into this house
obviously means we don't have it in a
nest egg and borrowing it doesn't
fix that because we got it if you
borrowed on your house and say ok I'm
gonna put 200 down and end of my have
$100,000 mortgage well then you know you
still gotta pay the hundred thousand off
and that's still a hundred thousand it's
not going into my retirement nest egg so
what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes ok here's what I would do if I
woke up in your shoes I don't know what
you'll do but this is what I would do I
would buy a $200,000 house for cash
which in your area ain't much of a house
ok it's an OK house it's certainly not a
Shack but it's a pretty far step down
from where you were living I understand
that when I'm saying this I'm going
somewhere with this don't quit on me
till we finish talking ok so I would
start there and I pay off my car today
find out what the early buyout on it is
is probably around 12 grand probably 11
10 11 grand something like that and find
out what the buyout is and just pay the
stupid thing off and own the car okay or
sell it and get one that you pay cash
for I don't care
spend ten or twelve thousand dollars
doing that twenty thousand bucks
whatever it takes let's get out of this
car lease no more payments now we got
zero payments now in my little scenario
of the world I just invented okay and
we've got $50,000 or so to start
investing start our investing process
into good mutual funds then you load up
a SEP you load up a Roth IRA and you do
everything you can to increase the
number of accounts you keep books for
and let's increase your income and let's
bust it for a few years now
if we can get you up to a half-million
dollars in savings for your retirement
in a few years and you want to move up
in house and pay cash for the move up
that'll be okay that means we've gotten
past the danger zone but you retiring
with zero money or close to zero money
and a nice paid for house is not a plan
and so I'm gonna scale your house back
to get the other stuff started and then
you know in five years when you see that
this is working and you want to move up
in house again move up to about a four
hundred and pay cash for it and you know
I think you'll be able
to do that later in this plan but I want
you to make sure we first have got the
wolf away from the door
mm-hmm so I would live in that $200,000
house for three to five years while I
got my nest egg roaring and when it's
roaring and it's going big it's on fire
then I'm talking about saving up paying
cash moving up in house a little bit and
we know we're gonna be okay I think
you'll be okay if you do all of this and
you live on a tight budget but you have
not done that to date today you've not
saved a dime in 59 years on the planet
so you got some proving to do to
yourself not to me but to yourself that
you can do this and you need to scale
this house down with no house payment to
enable that to happen and you need to
get on the every dollar budget so hold
on I'm gonna do two things I want you to
go through Financial Peace University
and I'm gonna show you how to be a
millionaire in 14 years and you can do
that making $70,000 a year especially in
your situation because you get two
hundred nine thousand bucks in the bank
you got a good start on this okay so um
you hold on I'll have Madison sign you
up and that's gonna hook you up with
every dollar plus when you do the
membership it includes the class every
dollar plus all the other classes legacy
journey everything's in there so you
hold on and we'll give you that as our
gift the other thing we're gonna send
you is Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired his first number-one bestseller
and you that's what we're trying to do
here we're trying to take you a 59 years
old and get you respite it's you're
retiring inspired and that that's what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes I'm
not I don't know if you'll do it or not
but that that's a really good
mathematical system I just gave you
there and it will work I promise you it
will work if you push it through